genocide from someone taking a break
from whatever issues are are going on
how can they step outside of their story
I think it's so hard when this is the
only life we've known and this is our
badge and our chip on our shoulder for
whatever's happened to us how do we step
outside of our own story for a moment
well I think the gift that writing gives
the writer is the ability to go into the
fictional world and when you go into the
fictional world say for example you're
gonna write a TV spec instead of an
original so there is a gift in that
because you're moving outside of you
know I think the biggest mistake writers
make is when they write a pilot that is
more autobiographical versus just
drawing from their emotional truths and
the difference is when you're when
you're writing something
autobiographical you're too stuck you're
too in it and you're too like well it
didn't happen that way or this didn't
happen or that didn't happen and I work
with writers a lot on that and I'll say
like when you look at the movie Nixon
and you go okay the most pivotal moment
in that movie has to do with the drunken
phone call that didn't happen yet it was
an incredible thing for the movie to
have in it because it was dramatic story
and that's what needs to happen it's
really taking the framework of a
situation and then I I think the
greatest thing writers do is you add
your own worldview to what the story is
so I think that when you have a writer
that's writing a TV spec a lot of
writers will say well I can't use my
voice in a TV spec and it yes you can
use your voice your if you identify with
one of the characters in a very unique
way because of your personal
background then you can escape from your
pain and being totally in everything
that is and move it into a character
that is separate from your world but use
your emotional truths because you
identify with that character to drive
them action wise so if you look at one
of their scripts and you see them as the
hero but they're portraying themselves
as the villain or vice versa they see
themselves as a hero and you see them as
anything but that do you try to guide
them another way or that's just their
truth so that doesn't matter well it all
depends on what is working for the story
you know I I would say you know when I
look at as I mentioned the night manager
in Happy Valley like what I noticed in
both of those series that I thought was
so brilliant were the antagonists were
incredible and so I I do think that
there's so much we can learn from
developing the antagonist understanding
the antagonist moving with the
antagonist and I I think that if writers
are seeing themselves and what I mean I
find that most of the writers I work
with tell me they see themselves and
almost all the characters they write so
the good part of that is they're not
narrowly narrowly looking at one
character and saying okay this is me and
you can certainly recognize that when
they get stuck in something that is so
modeled after them then I think it's
it's not necessarily saying I know this
is modeled after you and therefore
you're not doing this it's saying this
character isn't working in this
situation because of blank and it's
separating so that they can separate
themselves and there
story and recognize that you're guiding
the story so that it's going to move in
a stronger direction
you